pour ces gens dit merci beaucoup
monsieur
[Musique]
souvent les personnes âgées sont un peu
délaissé sans oublier et surtout
aujourd'hui dans la société
d'aujourd'hui où ça pousse au jeunisme
voilà il faut être jeune faut être frais
c'était juste le temps d'un instant
partager un petit moment avec un moment
d'amour et voir dans ce genre de
situation où ou personnes pensent à eux
alors qu'ils ont construit le monde dans
lequel on vit
bah c'est touchant en fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on se rend compte qu'en fait en france
et ça c'est culturel général c'est que
on prend plus le temps pour le céser
mais on prend le temps de les voir on
lui prend peut-être plus au sérieux
alors que c'est eux qui ont tous ceux
qui ont une expérience qu'on le
savoir-faire moi j'ai grandi avec des
valeurs un peu africaine ou où les
parents bas en fait c'est qui nous élève
c'est qu'ils nous font grandir et quand
il arrive à un stade où ils peuvent plus
travailler basse etc les jeunes c'est
des enfants qui reprennent la relève est
qui qui prennent soin d'eux en fait et
je connaissais pas ce genre
d'établissement là et j'ai été vraiment
j'ai été touché en fait franchement si
un jour je finis tout seul comme ça
oubliez que plus personne ne vient me
voir parce que c'est les gens plus
personne ne vient les voir souvent leurs
enfants leurs propres aux enfants et à
une dalle comme tu dis ça fait cinq ans
qu'on n'avait pas vu sa fille et où je
me suis dit est ce que j'aimerais cette
personne-là est franchement dans le
premier le temps pour pour vos aînés
pour vos proches parce qu'on sait pas de
quoi demain est fait que tout va
tellement vite
et hier on avait besoin d'eux
aujourd'hui ils ont besoin de nous vous
pouvez changer leur vie et leur donner
le sourire pendant toute la journée donc
voilà prenez une heure ou deux dans la
semaine sans coutras et nous sentirions
même mieux vous
et tout et tout